The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: You have to
make some design decisions.
And then once you've made
those design decisions,
then you can actually write your
level 2, level 3 requirements
and so forth, it's
an iterative process.
But when you look at
the classic v model,
you don't really see
those iterations.
But they actually exist.
So what we typically do
at the system requirements
review is we review and
then agree on the high level
requirements, level
0, level 1, maybe
level 2 requirement, but
not the lower level ones,
because you can't,
because you typically
haven't done the design yet.
The other thing I want
to say is a lot of the--
this is really a critical issue.
And a lot of the problems
we talked about last time
in the schedule, cost overruns,
really, a lot of these things
are traceable back
to the requirements.
Either the requirements
were over ambitious.
You can set requirements that
were essentially unachievable.
Or you missed requirements that
actually became clear later on.
But they weren't written.
So nobody paid
attention to them.
A couple of examples.
So I have sort of one
example of core requirements,
and then a good example.
So this is a mission that
you may have heard about.
A 1998 MCO.
So who was born in--
I'm looking at you guys.
Justin, right?
Justice, when were you born?
'94?
OK, so you're older
than MCO by four years.
So MCO was a very well-known
just about not quite
20 years ago, a very well known
mission failure that happened.
A Mars climate orbiter, it
was launched on December 1998.
And it had multiple functions
study the Martian climate,
weather and surface changes.
And it was to act as a relay
satellite for the Mars polar
Lander, which came after
it and also failed.
Both failed.
And unfortunately MCO burned up.
We think contact was
lost with a spacecraft
after it basically entered
the Martian atmosphere.
And you know nothing-- there
was no more communication.
So we don't know for sure.
But their best guess is that
the spacecraft burned up
in the approach to Mars, that
the actual altitude at which
had entered the
Martian atmosphere
was about 57 kilometers.
And it was supposed
to be about 220.
So even though the Martian
atmosphere is very thin,
when you enter at
very high velocities,
that's not a good thing.
This is the very famous--
you've heard about this--
confusion of units problem,
like this mission that one
part of the team used SI units,
specifically Newton's seconds,
this is momentum, right?
Force times time, that
gives you momentum.
So when you burn your engines
for x number of seconds
the sum of the product of
those two is your momentum.
And then another
part of the team
used English units, pounds
of force times second.
OK, and so that was
fundamentally the problem that
caused the burn up.
Now if you read the
accident report.
And I have a link here
to the accident report,
you will notice that the
requirements were actually OK.
The requirements were
written correctly.
So specifically, there was a
document called the software
interface specification, SIS,
that specified everything
should be in SI units
on the ground segment
and on the space segment.
But the problem is that this
was not checked and implemented.
And so here's a quote
from the accident report.
Items that the mission
assurance manager, which
didn't exist for this mission.
So the mission
Assurance Manager role
is to make sure the requirements
are actually followed.
There was no mission Assurance
Manager on the MCO mission.
Included ensuring that
the AMD file, which
is one of the files put out
by the propulsion system,
met the requirements
of the softwares
in the interface specification
And that did not happen.
And so that was sort of
the root cause there.
Here's a good example
for requirements.
This is a little bit older.
This is the DC-3.
This is an old plane.
First flight in December 1935.
This was this was
really an airplane that
kickstarted civil aviation
as a commercial service.
And so first of
all, the DC-3 was
based on an earlier
evolution of the DC-2.
And I first saw this when
I worked in St. Louis.
There was a little museum
at the headquarters.
And they had like a, like
a nice plaque on the wall
with actually a replica
of the contract.
You know, the original letter
that left the DC-3 contract.
And the story is that
this-- these requirements--
these are--
this is level 0 requirements,
what's written here,
was hammered out
in a single quote,
end quote marathon phone call
between Smith and Douglas.
So Smith was, at that
time, the head of what
was today essentially
United Airlines.
And Douglas, who by the way, is
a graduate of this department
here at MIT, Donald Douglas,
was the head of the Douglas
Aircraft Company.
And here are the requirements:
range about 1,000 miles.
So this means that you don't
have a trans-continental range,
right?
If you want transcontinental
range in the US,
you need about how many miles?
Like Boston to San
Diego, Seattle to Miami.
3,000?
Yeah, reserves.
Yeah, 3,000 miles.
So this means that, if you go
transcontinental with the DC-3,
you've got to refuel
twice, basically.
But you know, that was OK.
Today, we wouldn't-- we
probably wouldn't accept it.
But that's OK back then.
Cruise speed about 150 miles.
20 to 30 passengers, depending
on the configuration.
Twin engines.
And then something that
we would say today.
That's a fuzzy-- that's a not
a well written requirement,
because it's fuzzy.
But it said, it should be
a rugged and economical.
And based on this sort of
high level requirements
that were pretty
clearly defined,
the airplane was
then designed, built,
and very, very successful.
And over 10,000 copies of
this airplane were built.
So what happened since then
is the requirements explosion.
This is a chart from
a document called
the technical multi-disciplinary
design optimization
white paper.
And it's a little dated,
but the basic message here
is pretty stunning if
you think about it.
So first, heavier
than air flight,
1903, the Wright
brothers, right?
1G flight.
What is the requirement
for 1G flight?
Get off the ground.
And stay off the ground for
at least a few seconds, right?
Not just ballistic.
That's the requirement.
Get off the ground.
Heavier than air flight.
Yeah, big success.
Big milestone.
Well, pretty clear after
not too long, it was well--
we also want to turn.
We don't want to
just fly straight
on the beach and land again, so
maneuvering, gust acceleration.
There are winds buffeting.
You've got to
handle those gusts.
So that that's important.
And then what were the
first airplanes made of?
Let's see an EPFL, guys.
What's the first airplanes?
What materials did they use?
[STATIC]
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Wood.
PROFESSOR: Wood, yeah.
What else?
AUDIENCE: Canvas.
PROFESSOR: Canvas.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
so then very soon after that,
maybe in the 20s and 30s,
we started using metals, right?
Metallic structures.
And the big issue there,
especially if you're
flying close to the
ocean and salt water,
is corrosion control.
Your airplanes can't rust.
And so a corrosion
control became important.
And pressurization,
what is that all about?
Higher, faster.
So at some point, you need to
pressurize the cabin, right?
That's a new requirement.
The Wright brothers
never thought about that.
Well, they didn't-- maybe
they thought about it.
But they certainly didn't have
to pressurize their Wright
flyer.
So you see you see what's
happening is we get greedy.
You know, we were excited.
We can fly now.
But now we want to go higher.
We want to stay longer.
So we get greedy.
And we go to more extreme
environments and so forth.
And as we do that, it get
harvested do and more and more
requirements start piling up.
And you see a big step
here, World War II, right?
Handling quality,
radar transparency.
Radar was invented.
So now you want to
have airplanes that
are not visible on the radar.
Fatigue, rough field landing.
And then we have another big
step here in the 60s and 70s.
This was during the Cold
War, smart weapons, nuclear,
fly by wire, right?
Replacing cables with
electronic flight controls.
And then a lot of the
"ilitys" in the last 20 years,
reducibility, affordability,
portability, et cetera.
So if you actually look
at the requirements set
for the new generation
of airplanes,
whether commercial or
military, it's overwhelming.
I mean, it's thousands and
thousands of requirements,
because we've gotten greedy.
And we've gotten good at it.
So we keep adding
more requirements.
And that's a big
issue right now.
And we'll talk later
in the semester
about complexity management.
But the key message
here is requirements
have been growing over time.
More and more requirements
added as systems grow
and in performance
and complexity.
So here's some standards.
I won't go through
those in detail.
But people recognize, in the
system engineering community,
how important it is,
these requirements.
So in the system
engineering handbook,
there's two sections, 4.2, which
is about technical requirements
definition, and
then section 6.2,
which is about
requirements management.
So definition means that's
the initial definition
of the initial requirement.
And then management
is the process
of updating them, adding
requirements, modifying them,
making sure they're up to date.
And there are a
couple of appendices.
INCOSE, the International
Council of System Engineering
has, in the handbook,
a whole section.
There's even a requirement
working group, people
who really specialize
in this, and then
as well in the ISO
standard, you have a lot
written about requirements.
So this is really a big deal.
So the last thing I want
to do here in this section
is to sort of, at
a very high level,
communicate to you what
requirement really are about.
What they are about
is, like I said,
don't set off in your
ship without-- you
don't know what port
you're sailing to, right?
So requirements set goals
and constrain the design
in the objective space.
So whatever you're
designing, you're
always going to have two spaces
that you're dealing with.
The design space,
on the one hand,
that's the things you
can choose as a designer.
These are the
knobs you can turn,
the decisions you can make.
And then the
objective space, which
is the things that, essentially,
your customer cares about.
I'll give you a
quick example here.
So when we use the word shall,
which I'll get to in a minute.
The English word, shall,
means this is essentially
a constraint.
You must accomplish this.
And when you use the word,
should, it's more like a goal.
It would be nice to do this.
But it's not
absolutely mandatory.
So shall is a hard constraint.
Should it is
desirable as a goal.
So let me give you this
quick example here.
So let's say you're
designing a house.
You're about setting
off to design a house.
And what would be some
requirements for a house.
So I wrote four of them here.
And I'll map them to the design
space and the objective space.
First requirement,
the house shall sleep
between four and six people.
Well, is that in
the design space
or in the objective space?
That's in the
objective space, right?
Yeah, that's right.
So here, we have an axis
called occupance, right?
So four is the minimum and
six is sort of the maximum.
So that's the upper bound.
The next one, the
total build cost
should be less than $550,000.
Should be.
What is that?
Maybe an EPFL.
AUDIENCE: It's a goal.
PROFESSOR: It's a goal.
Yup, that's right.
And is it in the design
space or the objective space?
AUDIENCE: The objective space.
PROFESSOR: That's correct.
So I put this as a dashed line,
OK, because it's a should.
So what I've done here, just
by writing these two sentences,
these two requirements, is I've
essentially carved out a space,
right?
And I can shape that box.
Basically, what these
two requirements
do is they put a box around
in the objective space saying
that, whatever house
you're going to design,
it has to fit within this box.
Then the third one is the house
shall have at least at least
three bedrooms.
What is that?
In the design space
or objective space?
Design space, right?
Because defining a bedroom
is a design decision, right?
And the house should
have a fireplace.
So you can show the lower bound
here, at least three bedrooms.
And then the fireplace is a--
it would be nice to have.
But you don't absolutely
have to have it.
So you can sort of draw this--
it's more like a
line here, right?
Yes, fireplace.
But it's a dashed line.
And then at least
three bedrooms.
So just these four
sentences, we've now put a--
we've defined the space that
we're going to be designing in.
So we have constraints
in the design space.
And we have constraints
in the objective space.
And that's fundamentally
the role of requirement
is to constrain, to give
us direction as to what
we're going to design.
OK, so let's do our first
concept question for today.
And that's the
following question,
do you think there's a
fundamental difference
in the meaning
between the words,
requirements, which we've
talked about so far,
and then the word,
specifications,
which I haven't mentioned yet.
So no, you think they're
essentially the same.
Yes, there is a difference.
Requirements are like the
input, and specifications
are the output of
the design process.
Yes, you think a difference.
Specifications include the
requirements as a subset.
Or you're not sure.
So think about this.
And then submit your answers.
And as far as these
URLs are concerned,
for the concept questions,
I went to all lowercase.
Hopefully, that's a
little bit easier.
So secc3.
tiny.cc/secc3.
What do you think?
Requirements and specifications.
The same thing or not?
Who needs more time?
Anybody?
OK.
OK, so we have nobody
thinks they're the same.
62 thirds of you think that
requirements are the input,
specifications are the output.
9 of you think that
requirements are a subset.
And then 6% are not sure.
So that's good.
I agree with that.
So a lot of people use
requirements and specifications
as the same thing.
They're really not.
OK, so think of requirements
and you haven't actually
started to design that.
This is your putting
constraints in the design space,
defining the direction.
But we don't actually know
what the design will look like.
You may have some requirements
may say you must use this box,
or you must use
this sensor, right?
And you might actually find
some of those in the CanSat.
But basically the
requirements are the input.
So any-- What are
your experiences?
When have you heard those terms,
requirements or specifications
used interchangeably
or not interchangeably?
Has this come up as an
issue for you before?
[? Marissa, ?]
you're worked at--
you're worked on human
spaceflight, right?
Space tourism vehicles.
So what-- how did you guys
do it at Virgin Galactic?
AUDIENCE: Well,
I think something
that you generally saw was like
people will look at sensors.
And they would-- there's a
specification for a sensor.
And they would not necessarily
compare the requirements
to the specification.
So or they would not understand
how the two intersected.
So I think there was a
bit of a misunderstanding
of the difference between what
the actual requirements were,
versus what the specifications
were designed to be.
PROFESSOR: The sensors
you're talking about
would be sensors, I'm assuming,
that you would purchase, right?
As commercial--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, absolutely.
So I think we were
buying of the shelf.
And so I mean, sometimes
the specifications
were broader than what we
wanted and sometimes they
were narrower.
But you know, you can do
additional testing on it.
So there was sometimes a
breakdown between understanding
really whether the sensor met
what we are looking for or it
didn't.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Good.
What about an EPFL.
Any experiences? [? Walker, ?]
you worked on slip rings,
right?
Slip rings was one of the big
specialties of your company.
I'm assuming that
you guys had to make
that distinction, right?
Between requirements
and specifications.
What are your thoughts
at EPFL on this?
GUEST SPEAKER: Well,
yes, from outside,
we clearly had a separation
also on an ether level.
But I was wondering
here in the class,
has anybody seen the difference
between specification
requirements?
Any comments?
Maybe some of the
PhD students that
have been around the block?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, OK, great.
So I found here, I,
you know, I wanted
to sort of find a real
example that everybody can
relate to very, very easily.
So the answer is there
is a distinction.
They are quite different.
But they're-- got to be careful,
because you can mix them up.
So requirements specify what
the product or system should--
shall or should do, right?
Functions it shall perform, how
well it should perform these.
Also maybe the
degree of autonomy,
how automated is the system?
So what the operators must do,
when the system is operating.
And also compatibility
with other devices.
And then specifications are
about how the system is built
and how it actually works.
So the form, right?
What the materials
that are used,
the dimensions,
schematics, blueprints,
the details of the
user interface.
Those are things-- those
are all specifications.
So I try to look up a very
simple consumer product
that we all are familiar
with, a microwave oven.
Kenmore Elite Countertop
2.2 cubic foot.
You go to Sears website.
And what's interesting is they
actually do a pretty good job.
It's actually pretty consistent
with what I'm saying here,
except they don't talk
about requirements.
They call it description.
So what's listed on
their description.
And this is, I'm pretty
much quoting here, verbatim.
This microwave is large enough
to accommodate the big dishes,
right?
So the idea is this is sort
of family style, right?
This is not a small microwave
just for a frozen meals.
This is-- you should be able
to put a big casserole in it.
And reheat meals and so forth.
So the idea that what
are the things you're
going to use in the microwave.
What's the use case, right?
CONOPS.
CONOPS for the microwave.
You know, family, for kids,
both parents are working,
busy, you know,
not time to spend
two hours preparing dinner.
Therefore, big dishes,
a lot of people.
It has to be quick, right?
That's a CONOPS.
And the requirements,
this description,
is essentially the requirement.
1,200 watts of power
to reheat food quickly.
So time is important.
And then one touch settings
for different food types,
rice, pizza, frozen meals.
And that, what is that?
That's automation, right?
Rather than having to
guess how long and at what
power level to reheat, there's
some partial automation
built in.
That's essentially
requirements, very user centric.
Do you see that?
And then when you look
under specification,
it says the following things:
stainless steel exterior,
right?
Again, you don't
want it to rust.
The dimensions, the weight.
There's a general
warranty one year.
The power cord is included.
It's very different.
Those are things that describe
how it's made, the form of it,
and so forth.
So make sure you
keep those separate.
OK, so let me talk about the
NASA requirements process.
And then we'll talk
about challenges.
So getting back to the
system engineering engine.
That's sort of the heart of
the NASA system engineering
process.
You remember, this is the--
this happens at every
level of decomposition.
After stakeholder expectations.
The second step is technical
requirements definition.
And there's some pretty strong
language in the handbook
that this really
has to be done well.
So the center directors
or their designees
shall establish and
maintain a process
to include activities,
requirements, guidelines,
documentation for the definition
of technical requirements.
So I think I've
already said this,
but I just want to make it
clear again, this is kind of--
I like this cartoon.
This is Moses, right?
Up on thee--
Moses just got the
tablets, right?
The stone tablets.
They-- the 10 commandments.
And one of them is,
thou shalt not steal.
And God says, out of
the clouds, no, they're
requirements, not goals, right?
So what God is saying is that
the 10 commandments are, shall,
right?
And not should.
Even though, I think, some of
us don't always succeed at that.
But that's basically the idea.
Shall is a very hard constraint.
And that's what you
will be judged against.
And should is essentially
a desirable goal.
But the degree of attainment
is somewhat flexible.
Why are we doing this?
Why are we spending our time
writing technical requirements?
It's essentially to transform
those stakeholder expectations
we talked about last
time, transform them
into measurable
technical requirements.
Requirements come in
different flavors.
And I'll mention those flavors.
And we express them in
these shall statements.
They also provide a
basis for agreement
among the stakeholders
and developers.
So you will often find
requirements part of contracts,
right?
Now it becomes serious, you
know when the requirements set
actually has legal implications.
You're legally signing up
to develop a system that
will meet these requirements.
That's pretty serious stuff.
By writing good
technical requirements,
you can reduce the development
effort, because of less rework.
So a lot of rework and
iterations and confusion
is based on missing or poorly
written requirement, right?
And writing those early and
before the design begins
is helpful.
A requirements set is also a
basis for cost and schedule
estimates.
And so some of these
missions that overran.
Do you remember I showed
you this chart last time.
We analyzed 40 missions, earth
and space science missions.
Like 20% of them were
responsible for 80%
of the overruns.
A lot of that had to do
with unrealistic goals
or expectations
and requirements.
And then the next point here is
that the requirements provide
the basis for verification.
In other words, the
better, the more
crisp, the better written
your requirements are,
the easier it is
to test the system
and to check whether these--
whether the system
is in compliance
with the requirements.
And then, eventually,
the basis for acceptance.
Acceptance is also
a big deal, right?
It basically means,
I accept your design.
I take ownership of it.
And I say, you, as the
developer of the system,
have done your job properly.
And there's a legal transfer
of the assets that happens.
So facilitates the transfer
of the product to the users.
And then even later,
if you're going
to do it like a
version 2 or a block
upgrade, a next
generation product,
it's much easier to do when
you have a clear requirements,
because it tells you what the
original system or the earlier
version was able
to do or not do.
Graphically.
So this is figure 4.0.1.
I briefly talked
about this last time.
We start, essentially,
here at the development.
We have mission authority.
We do the stakeholder
expectations.
We talked about that last time.
And then here, right away,
comes a high level requirement.
So that means your level
0, level 1 requirement.
And then as you try to get more
detailed in the requirements,
what do you think happens?
Ideally, you want to
write all the requirements
upfront, right?
That would be great.
But you try to do
that, you hit a wall.
Why is that?
What's the issue?
Why can't we just write
all the requirements
and then be done
with it in one shot?
Yes.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Well, your
system changes over time.
And some of the
requirements clash.
And you can't achieve all
of them simultaneously.
PROFESSOR: Yes. so there's
two things you mentioned.
So one is the sort of--
and I'll talk.
This is known as,
requirements volatility,
like the requirements are
changing as you learn more
about the problem.
And then the other is you detect
conflict between requirements.
And you have to clean those up.
Those are two very valid issues.
But it's not quite
what I was going for.
AUDIENCE: There's another
one, requirements creep,
in which your customer levies
these new requirements on you,
once you've started the process.
PROFESSOR: Yes, so new
requirements get added.
Hopefully, you get
more budget, too.
That doesn't always
happen, right?
So that's another issue.
But it's a little different.
Let's see, EPFL, you guys.
Why don't we write like all four
or five levels of requirements
all at once?
Why can't we do that, typically?
Why do you think?
AUDIENCE: Usually, the other
requirements aren't clear.
They don't exist yet.
Later on in the process,
they become clear.
And you start to realize
the details, which at first,
you don't.
PROFESSOR: That's-- I think
that's pretty close to what
I'm looking for.
So the issue is you do your
level 0, level 1 requirements.
And then sort of as
you get to level 2,
you can't really write
that level 2 requirement
until you've made some
key design decisions.
Are we going to use electric
propulsion or are we going
to use chemical propulsion?
You know, that's a huge
decision in space system design.
And unless you've
made that decision,
you can't really write
lower level requirements,
because the fundamental
working principles
of chemical and electrical
propulsion are quite different.
So that's the key issue is that
you can only do the high level
requirements in a
solution neutral space.
And then you hit the
wall, because you've
got to make some key concept
technology selection decision.
And that's shown
here by this red box
called functional and
logical composition.
I don't like that
nomenclature a lot.
This should really say,
system architecture
or concept selection,
which we'll get
into in the next couple weeks.
Once you've chosen a high
level architecture and concept,
then you say, OK, we're going
to go for ion propulsion.
Well, then you can
write the requirements
for the ion propulsion
system, which
are we through the find
in this yellow box here.
So this is your design
and product structure,
derived an allocated
requirements at lower levels.
You see that?
That's the fundament--
all the things you said,
requirements creep
requirements conflict.
All those things are true.
But the fundamental
reason why we
can't write all the
requirements upfront,
because, at some point, the
lower level requirements depend
on design decisions made.
That's the fundamental issue.
OK, any questions
about that point?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: It's not
totally about that point.
But it's still like--
So requirements
versus specification.
So if you're like
buying a component
from a vendor, some
piece of hardware,
and you want identify like
the specific locations
where it should
attach to things,
it's more of like a form
as opposed to really--
so does that fall
into requirements
or is that like a specification?
PROFESSOR: Great point.
So there are-- what
you're describing
is a peculiar type
of requirement
that we call interface
requirements.
And it's a perfect
segue to this next--
you know, if I
could only include
like I don't five
slides in this lecture,
this would be one of them.
This basically is what
are the different flavors
of requirements or
types of requirements.
And there are six of them here.
So first of all, the
functional requirements.
I think we've sort of
talked about those, right?
Define the functions that
need to be done to accomplish
the mission objectives.
There's some examples here
around thrust vector control.
So basically, the
idea here is that you
have a thrusting system.
And it has or you can
actually direct the thrust.
And in this case, you
should control the thrust.
You shall provide thrust control
around pitch and your axes.
So this statement is a high
level functional statement.
And it's written in the actor
verb, object form, right?
So that's sort of the
classic, you know,
the classic requirement and
the functional requirement.
And then we have
performance requirements.
The performance requirements
are, in a sense,
qualifiers on the
functional requirements.
So a performance
requirement will
specify how well the
function should be performed,
how fast should it
fly, how much thrust.
You know, this is where you
have to actually put numbers in.
So in this case, this
thrust vector controller
shall gimbal the engine
9 degrees, right?
That's the deflection
angle, at least 9 degrees,
plus or minus 1 degree, degree.
0.1 degree.
That's the performance
requirement.
Then we have constraints.
OK, yeah?
STUDENT: Isn't the
performance department saying
that the engine has
to gimbal 9 degrees,
isn't that kind of pushing
toward the specification.
Or is that?
I mean, I guess, is can
also be a requirement.
But isn't that?
PROFESSOR: Right, in
this case, we have a set,
and we're not specifying how
those 9 degrees are achieved,
you know, whether it's through
a gimbal or the actual mechanism
or how it's not described here.
All that's described is
the angular [? range, ?]
essentially, that this.
And that is a
performance requirement.
But you'll see, there
will be some examples
of things that are putting
limits on the form, which looks
more like a specification.
So then we have constraints.
Constraints are things on
like weight, mass, power,
things like that.
So constraints are requirements
that cannot be traded off with
respect that cost,
schedule, or performance.
So for example, the prospector
controller unit module
shall weigh less
than 120 pounds.
So that's a-- that's not,
if you think about it,
that is not functional, right?
The weight of the
thrust vector controller
shall not be more than 100--
that is not performance.
It's not functional requirement,
but it's a constraint
on the form, essentially.
So this looks more like what
we would call a specification
constraint.
The fourth one is what
[? Marissa ?] brought up.
This is an interface
requirement.
OK, so in this case, our
thrust vector controller
shall interface with
the J-2x The J-2x is
a very famous engine.
And J-2x is a kind of--
this is sort of,
this was written
during the constellation days
of the constellation program
at NASA is the idea of a new
generation of the J-2 engine.
So the idea is that
whatever you do,
however you design your
thrust vector controller,
it must be able to interface
with the J-2x engine,
according to
conditions specified
in this interface
control document.
So this is called an
interface requirement.
Then the fifth category are
environmental requirements.
So the TVC shall use [? Biber ?]
acoustic shocks and loads
according, again, to some
environmental document.
And by the way, for
the CanSat competition,
we have that, right?
There's two documents.
There's the mission guide.
And then there's this
environmental testing guide.
So what this essentially says
is under what conditions shall
the performance,
and functional--
the functions and
performance that
are specified in
the first two type
of requirements, under
what conditions shall that
be performed, right?
And if anything
you think about it,
designing whether it's
a sensor or anything
to operate between 0 degrees
Celsius and 30 degrees Celsius
or between minus 60 and plus
80, is a huge difference, right?
You can write that down.
But what that actually
means to open up
the range of
environmental conditions,
it has a big, big
impact on the design.
And so this is a big
deal in practice.
And then, at least in
Space Systems design,
you know a lot of these
environmental requirements
are of course, driven by the
space environment or the launch
environment.
If you're designing
airplanes, whether you're
flying in a small mountainous
country like Switzerland
or on the ocean off of
an aircraft carrier,
those are very
different environments.
And they're going to influence.
You have to specify the
operating requirement.
The bigger the
envelope that you make
for the environmental
requirements, the more complex
the system will be.
Also medical-- anybody working
on medical devices here?
EPFL.
Anybody?
Medical devices?
So in medical devices,
it's the same thing.
Is this medical
device going to be
used in a hospital
setting, where
everything is kind of clean.
You have clean power.
The nurses, everybody
is very well-trained.
That's one thing.
Or is his medical device
going to be used in the field,
you know?
In Africa, in India, in a rural
area, where people are not,
maybe not trained, medically
and professionally and so forth.
Very different.
The function may be the same.
But the environmental
conditions are very different.
You have to really
specify those.
And then we have-- the last
category is kind of the other.
It's sort of a catchall.
But it can be very important.
So this includes a lot of the
human factors, reliability
and safety requirements.
Those are-- and you know,
they're listed here as other.
And I think it's
really important
to say that just because
they're listed here
doesn't mean they're
less important.
These are often
neglected, unfortunately.
And it really can hurt
you in the long term.
So pay attention to those
human factors, reliability,
and safety requirements.
So six types of requirements.
So let's talk about what
makes good or acceptable
requirements.
And there's a distinction here
between a single requirement
statement and then
sets of a requirements.
So first of all,
requirements should
be written in natural language.
They should be
complete sentences.
And each of the
requirement statements
should be clear and consistent,
meaning that it's not a novel
or it's not a poem.
But it's clear.
It's understandable.
It's well-written.
It's correct.
There's no errors in it.
It's feasible.
Now that's a really tricky one.
That's the first thing
here that's really tricky,
when you think about it.
Feasible means, what?
It means this requirement
can be satisfied
within the laws of physics and
state of the art technologies
and other project constraints.
So why is that a tricky one?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: I was going to ask
a question regarding that,
in terms of how do you
deal with a program
where you're working
on things or you're
trying to actually maybe
define the state of the art
or figure out what is feasible.
PROFESSOR: Right.
so if you're basically
designing a product or a project
or a system that's a repeat
of what's already been done,
then you can have pretty
good confidence, right,
that those poles are feasible.
But what if you're
doing, let's say the--
I think I mentioned
this last time.
You're going to Europa.
And you're going to
drill through the ice.
And you're going to explore the
ocean under the ice in Europa.
It's never been done before.
You know, can we
actually do this?
So this is the tricky thing.
How ambitious, how ambitious
can the requirements
be and you still
claim feasibility?
And that's also one
of the big reasons
why programs get in trouble
is when they're actually
defining requirements that are
not really feasible within--
they're definitely way
beyond the state of the art.
And within the time frame
and budget allocated,
you can't get there.
And many, many programs
that run into this problem
are the ones where
the technologies
that you're going to use
are not really ready yet.
You know, there-- we'll
talk later about technology
readiness levels scale.
You're not really
ready yet to do this,
but you're going to try anyway.
So that's a tricky
one, feasibility.
Flexibility is, you
know, don't over specify
how things should be done.
So don't say how it
should be satisfied.
Without ambiguity.
That means if 10 people
read this requirement,
they should have the same or
very similar interpretation.
Singular statement, one
actor [? verb ?] object.
And then the last point
here is verifiability.
How are you going to
check whether or not
this requirement will,
in fact, satisfy you.
AUDIENCE: With regard
to that, the feasibility
again for some of
these programs I
had large, [? overrun ?]
schedule, overruns.
I mean, would it be
almost better in a sense
to have some of the requirements
be more shalls, like--
or goal.
In other words, you know, if
you can do this, go for it.
But if you're going
to run over 10 years,
maybe back off a
couple of percent.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
And what-- we'll talk
about this a little bit.
But if you-- all of them
are shall statements.
They're all hard constraints.
The objective space
that I showed you
may, in fact, have
0 feasible space.
So really knowing where, what
is a hard constraint, what
is a hard requirement,
and what is flexible,
that's very tricky.
And that's why it's important
to actually not just accept
requirements.
You know, if you're going to run
a project, every requirement,
you want to really
understand it.
And if you think this
requirement is infeasible,
you have to negotiate.
That's where the
upfront negotiation
becomes really important.
Did we lose our EPFL?
OK.
GUEST SPEAKER: Hello?
PROFESSOR: Go ahead, please.
GUEST SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Please, go for it.
AUDIENCE: So in 1990, we got
the requirements from NASA
to build a space
[? bioreactor. ?]
And all the students
will love this.
It was the smallest brewery
that ever flew in space.
And the initial requirements was
that all fluid containers had
to be solid with double walls.
And this meant that we had
another solution with bladders.
[INAUDIBLE] bladders.
So we had a real fight up
front in the proposal phase
to demonstrate the
compliancy to the requirement
of going the cell culture,
yeast cell culture,
and still being
non-compliant, actually,
to this requirement of hard
double-walled fluid containers.
And so this is exactly
[? the point, finding these ?]
[INAUDIBLE] since the
last 15 to 20 years.
And this was a
breakthrough in technology.
And there, you will always
have these challenges
with the agencies,
with your customers.
They are [INAUDIBLE]
set in their ways.
And you have to demonstrate
the feasibility to them
to make them change the
requirement that allows you
to change the specification.
PROFESSOR: No, I think
that's a great example.
So in the end, you were
successful to argue
for the bladder the
bladder solution.
GUEST SPEAKER: Well,
the bladder was just how
to keep the fresh medium and the
used medium, meaning the beer.
The technology was
to put in [INAUDIBLE]
And actually, it needed
to have flexibility
on the pressure
in the reservoir.
That's why the argument to
put [INAUDIBLE] in space
finally won the day,
and allowed to relax
the other requirements.
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
thank you, thank you.
A great example there.
Any other comments?
AUDIENCE: [COUGHING]
PROFESSOR: OK, so so all
this is a pretty long list.
And this applies to
single requirements.
And then there's a set of--
this is really important.
Then there's a set
of characteristics
that we want to see when you
look at sets of requirements,
groups that require.
Absence of redundancy.
This means that each requirement
is specified only once, right?
You don't want to
have redundancy.
Redundancy can be
good in system design,
but not in the requirements.
Consistency, using terms.
Completeness, this
basically means
not missing key requirements.
And then this idea of
absence of conflict.
And this is also similar
to the feasibility.
This is a tricky one.
Requirements can be in
tension with each other,
particularly their should goals.
But they shouldn't be in direct
conflict with each other,
like you know you shall
use aluminum for this unit.
And then another
requirements says, no metals
are allowed to be
used in this unit.
You can't.
That conflict is not solvable.
That's a direct contradiction.
That's different from having
competing requirements
or requirements in tension.
So let's do a quick exercise.
And then we'll actually
take a break, as well.
So this is a turn to
your partner exercise.
And then we'll have a break.
And we'll restart in
like about seven minutes.
So here's what I'd
like you to do.
I have three systems here.
They're very different
in scale and complexity.
So A is sticky tape.
And I'll tell you
this quick story here.
I grew up in Switzerland
surrounded by farms, you know.
And I spent all my
time at the farms
and you know, big
tables, big families.
And this is-- they
have these things here.
This is basically-- these
are flies sticking on tape.
This is to keep the flies
off the dinner table.
It's called Mr. sticky
tape for trapping flies.
Really kind of gross.
But I remember it.
B is I just a couple
of weeks ago had
a test drive and the new I3.
This is the BMW small
electric city car.
Very cool.
And then C is something that at
EPFL, you guys know very well.
This is the Rolex center.
It looks kind of
like Swiss cheese,
when you look from the top.
This is the equivalent
of W-20 here at MIT.
This is the student center.
So there's a library there.
There's a cafeteria
there and so forth.
So what I'd like you to do
is turn to your partner,
pick one of those
three, and come up
with one single statement,
one good requirement
that you think was possibly
used in the development
of that solution,
whichever one you pick, OK?
So pick one of those three.
And then jointly discuss
and write a requirement
that you think led
to this design, OK?
So take about five minutes.
Take a break.
And then we'll sample
what you came up with.
So let's hear from EPFL first.
did anybody do A?
AUDIENCE: We did A.
PROFESSOR: OK, go for it.
Speak up.
AUDIENCE: We had four
requirements for.
PROFESSOR: OK, go for it.
AUDIENCE: All right.
So The tape shows
[INAUDIBLE] of the tape
should be less than 4 grand.
The tape should be able
to catch up to 60 insects.
And the sticky tape should
not be toxic for humans.
PROFESSOR: OK, I like,
yeah, the toxicity.
That's good.
Excellent.
Very good.
ow who did A here at MIT.
Anybody?
A?
Go for it.
AUDIENCE: We said
if greater than 10%
of the surface area of the
fly contacts the paper,
it shall not be able
to release itself.
PROFESSOR: Ah, I see.
So this is a
trapping requirement.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, how
effective should it--
PROFESSOR: There are different,
very different flies, right?
There like these
little day flies.
And then there's
huge horseflies.
So which type of fly
did this apply to.
AUDIENCE: We said 10% of
the surface area of the fly.
PROFESSOR: Oh, any type of fly.
Any different fly species.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: OK.
All right, cool.
So go ahead.
Well, you know
the point of this.
You get the point
of this is, right?
A is like the sort of
you think trivial system.
But once you really
start thinking about it,
it's pretty tricky, right?
Who else wants to, A-- something
that hasn't been mentioned yet
on A. Sam, go for it.
Make sure you push the button.
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
for the sticky trap
we said that the product
shall fit on a store shelf
when packaged.
PROFESSOR: OK, so that's
kind of packaging,
logistics, distribution
requirement.
Very good.
Mike?
AUDIENCE: They kind of
already touched on it,
but the sticky tape shall
not be toxic and allow for--
allow for removal of human
skin without bodily harm.
PROFESSOR: OK, great.
So that's in the same--
you know, human factors
requirement, basically.
Yeah.
Very good.
Anything else on A at EPFL?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK, so
installation requirement.
OK.
Nobody mentioned the ones
I remember as a child are
bigger than this.
They were really long.
So capacity, right?
You could sort of have a
length or capacity requirement,
as well.
Good.
All right.
I think we want to move on from
the sticky flies to BMW i3.
So we had a little discussion
here during the break.
[? Lucy, ?] go for it.
AUDIENCE: So the car shell
meet environmental regulations
through mechanical or software
tweaking with a proposal.
PROFESSOR: Could you
guys hear this at EPFL?
You've been following
the news, right?
With Volkswagon.
So what happened?
Why did Volks-- the CEO
just step down, right?
It's kind of a big deal.
Trust in the company has eroded.
What happened there?
AUDIENCE: So the requirements
that were set at the start.
So the car shell meet
environmental regulations
on emissions.
This requirement was
probably not met.
But the realization that it
wasn't met was probably too
late in the design process,
such that it cannot be changed.
And so the easy or cheap way to
meet environmental regulations,
in that case, was to tweak
the software, I guess.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So by the way this is
kind of interesting.
But how do you measure
environmental compliance
of emissions for cars?
Do you know how that's
done in practice?
Do you guys know?
AUDIENCE: So it's having
[? the car ?] run on a--
having the engine run, but
the car is not rolling.
And there's, behind the
[FRENCH] the exhaust.
Behind the exhaust, you
measure whatever is emitted.
PROFESSOR: And it's like
another rolling carpet, right?
It's a dynamo, basically.
And the way they do it is they
have so-called drive cycles,
like the [? FT6 ?] drive cycle.
You know, the highway,
the city cycle,
which was a lot of on and off.
And those drive
cycles are actually
different in Europe and
the US and other countries.
Every country has
different drive cycles.
So that's-- and what is a
drive cycle, essentially?
What word would we, as
systems engineers, what word
would we put on it?
AUDIENCE: CONOPS.
PROFESSOR: A drive cycle
is just an, over time,
accelerations velocity
of the car, right?
STUDENT: It's a CONOPS.
PROFESSOR: It's a CONOPS
A drive cycle is a CONOPS.
And so for diesel
engines, this issue that
happened with
Volkswagen, it's only
an issue with the
diesel, the TDI engines,
right, not the gasoline engine.
So the issue is that the
CONOPS, the drive cycle,
in the US with TDI engines,
they couldn't meet it.
So they came up with
this trick, right?
Whereas in Europe,
they didn't have
to do that, because the European
drive cycle, there's a lot more
diesel engines use
in European cars.
They didn't have to do that
in Europe, because the CONOPS,
the drive cycle it's
used for checking
the environmental compliance
is different in Europe.
So great.
Anybody else on the I-3.
Now the I3 is interesting,
because that's actually
an electric car, right?
And so it doesn't have an
engine, a diesel engine
or a combustion engine, except
if you get the range extender.
So it's all
electric, but you can
actually, as an option get
the range extender, which does
use fuel.
OK, EPFL, the i3, any
other requirements there?
AUDIENCE: So we have
four [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: As a third one, the
car shall carry [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK, so recharging.
The third requirement
is interesting.
You said of average
build, right?
That's the word you use.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: Now that's great.
That's a human
factors requirement.
Now of average build is
a little fuzzy, right?
How would you make
that more verifiable?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so there's
actually people that, you know,
the size distribution, male,
female, you know, weight.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: And [INAUDIBLE]
the metric measurements
are actually being
recorded and updated.
People are getting
taller around the world.
People are getting heavier.
We know that, right?
So the way you would write
that third requirement
to be verifiable is that
the car shall accommodate
for passengers in a, say,
P10 male or P5 female
and a P90 male, right?
And if you write it that way,
then you know the actual weight
and dimensions of the
human body can actually
be traced to a database
that's pretty well known.
So then instead of
saying average build,
you say it's a PT50, P50 female.
And that's something
that's very verifiable.
Does that make sense?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: OK, great.
So what about the last one?
So by the way, here at MIT,
anybody who's been to EPFL?
Been to the-- [INAUDIBLE] He
has a Master's from there.
[INAUDIBLE] been there?
This is a very cool building.
It's pretty unusual.
I mean, we have some very
unusual building on campus,
too, here.
But if you get a
chance, it's pretty.
Unusual so let's
hear from you guys.
So what do you think was a
requirement for the [? Rolex ?]
center design?
AUDIENCE: The building should be
a recognizable structure, that
would be memorable for EPSL.
PROFESSOR: Ah, interesting.
A recognizable structure
that should be memorable.
So that's-- I think I know
where you're going with this.
But it's a little--
you know, recognizable.
Every building is recognizable
in a sense, right?
I think-- I like it.
I know where you're
going with this.
But it's a little
fuzzy still, right?
So why do you think
it has holes in it?
Why do you think the holes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] unique
might be a better word.
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So that's really.
The holes are, in some
sense, inefficient, right?
Because you're putting holes
in the middle of a building.
But they provide
natural lighting.
And there's a
symbolism there, right?
There's a symbolism, the
Swiss cheese symbolism.
So if the holes, in a sense,
have at least two functions,
right?
That's good.
I like that.
That's very good.
What else?
Another example of a requirement
for the [? Rolex ?] center?
AUDIENCE: You're taking and
making [INAUDIBLE] category.
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Good.
No, that was great.
So you have functional
requirement,
you had interface requirements.
You had a lot of
those six categories
we talked about, right?
Good.
Excellent.
Yeah?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So how do you write
a requirement about something
aesthetic in a way that's
not fuzzy or is there a way
to do that?
PROFESSOR: That's
a great question.
I'm not sure I'm the best
person to answer that.
What I can't tell you is,
in the automotive world,
the aesthetics of automobiles
and how people judge
whether a car is
beautiful or appealing,
that's actually moved from being
kind of just a very fuzzy thing
to quite measurable.
You know, there's
different shapes and then
the building blocks of
shapes and streamlines.
Those things are-- that's
really a science today.
And eventually, you
know, there's ratings.
These are people rate vehicles
for aesthetics and so forth.
And usually, it's a five point
scale, like a Likert scale,
like JD Power and associates
is a very well-known marketing
firm.
And so they'll say, this
looks-- this will prob--
they can actually,
at this point,
you can show them a-- not
a sketch, but a model.
And based on past data and
information, they'll tell you,
this car will probably
score between a 4.2 and 4.4
on the 5 point aesthetic
scale, JD Power scale.
It's really pretty remarkable.
But I guess the bigger point is
there's some things that really
delight us, that have
an artistic quality
and surprise us in
aesthetic quality.
And it's true.
That is one of the
tensions is yet--
system engineering should--
you know, this very precise.
Write it down.
Make sure there is no fuzziness
there or as little as possible.
And then on the
other hand, we want
delightful, surprising things
that have an artistic nature
to them.
And that is
absolutely a tension.
And we just acknowledge that.
OK, any questions?
Comments before we move on?
AUDIENCE: I had a
question about--?
PROFESSOR: Hang on.
Just one second.
OK, go ahead.
At EPFL?
AUDIENCE: And to which extent
can we refer [? to norms ?]
and [? loads ?] in
the requirements?
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
you should do that.
So compliance, being compliant
with standards and just
to make clear, standards
and regulations
are not the same, right?
A standard, like an IEEE
standard or an ISO standard,
it's not a law.
It's not a legal thing.
It's-- a standard it is
something that maybe a group
of companies or a group of
organizations have agreed to.
This is how we
will do it, right?
The IEEE Wi-Fi
standard, what is it?
802.11g.
And that's not a law.
That's a standard.
And if you're going to
be 802.11g compliant,
you write that in
the requirements.
The environmental emissions
standards we talked about,
those are actually laws.
If you are going to sell
a vehicle in country x,
it has to comply legally
with these regulations.
But you're absolutely
right, if you
need to comply
with these things,
it needs to be part of
the requirements set,
because otherwise, it will
not happen just automatically.
[? Weston? ?]
AUDIENCE: Yeah, it's
kind of along that vein.
If you have to
comply, say, with ADA,
instead you have to be
called out, specifically,
or do you say must comply with
building codes or building
laws?
And it's sort of a
blanket requirement?
PROFESSOR: No, you
have to be specific,
because building codes are,
first of all, a lot of these
are local, as well.
And it's very chaotic.
So and some of these
might be conflicting.
So you should be as
specific as possible.
OK, let's move on here.
My sense is you're getting it
just for what requirements are.
And why they're important.
So let me talk briefly about
requirements, decomposition,
allocation, and validation.
This is a figure from
the NASA handbook.
And basically, what it talks
about is the high level system
functional requirements
are broken down
into the performance
requirements.
And then as you make
design decisions,
as you decompose your system
into different subsystems,
each subsystem will have its
own functional and performance
requirements.
And then the important thing
is the difference between
allocated and
derived requirements.
So allocated requirements
are requirements
that you choose to allocate.
And then derived
requirements are calculated
based on the dependent
requirements,
based on the allocated
requirements.
And I'll get into
this in a minute.
So requirements
are hierarchical.
We talked about this.
Functional performance
requirements are allocated.
And then from these, we can
further decompose and derive
requirements.
And then the total set
of these requirements
needs to be verified
and then validated
against the stakeholder
expectations.
So let me briefly talk
about requirements margins
management.
So because you don't
know everything upfront,
there's uncertainty.
We typically build in reserves
into our requirements.
And those are called margins.
So we put in margins
for mass, power, maybe
memory in computer systems.
So margins are
essentially reserves
that are not allocated
to particular subsystems,
but are controlled by
the project managers
or at a higher level.
So the idea is that you
write the requirement
in a way that is a little bit
more stringent than it really
needs to be.
And then by being
more stringent,
you've built some
reserve into the system
to handle unexpected things.
So I'll just give you the
example with mass growth.
You know, this is very
typical in aerospace vehicles.
Mass growth can range
between, here, 10 to 60%.
I'll show you some examples.
And a lot of it depends on
the novelty of the project.
So a typical guideline,
specifically for mass margins,
is about 30% reserve at
the SRR, 20% PDR, 10% CPR,
and keep about 5% right
before you operate the system.
IOC is initial
operating capability.
So here's some historical data.
This is for manned
or crude vehicles,
starting with Mercury,
Gemini, Apollo,
Skylab, and then the shuttle.
You can see the mass growth
from the concept stage, which
is phase A or prephase A,
all the way to operations,
you know, between 10 and 60%.
The new Orion spacecraft is
not yet included on this chart.
So what you do is
you essentially write
the requirement, knowing
that this growth will happen
during the design process.
That's the basic
idea of margins.
And then the next
thing you get is
that you monitor
the satisfaction
of the requirements
during the design process.
And so let's say you have,
in a performance requirement,
you say that the
system shall not
emit more than x number
of [? NOX ?] emissions,
or the systems shall not be
heavier than such and such.
That's on the y-axis here.
That's your technical
performance measure.
And then you move through
time and, you know,
as the design gets
more detailed,
usually it gets heavier.
You add more things.
And you monitor that.
And then you have your
final current estimate
of where you will be at
the end of the project.
And as you do that, your limits,
your reserves, your margins,
and here there is an upper
and lower margin shown,
is going to be narrowing down.
I'll give you a quick example.
When I was at McDonnell Douglas,
the F18 EF version, the Super
Hornet, was being developed.
And the key thing
there was GTOW,
GTOW, gross take off weight.
It's basically the weight of
the plane with crew, fuel,
any payloads all in.
The gross take off weight of
the airplane, very important,
because it determines the range.
It determines a lot of things.
And the number, not
to exceed number,
which is shown here on this
chart as the maximum contract
or allocated
requirements threshold,
was contractually specified.
Not only that, but there were
penalties, financial penalties,
associated with every kilogram
that you would be over.
So this was a big deal.
And they had a
huge the wall chart
in the hallway,
the main hallway,
of the engineering building.
And every day somebody would
actually manually update
that day's best estimate of
what the gross take off weight
of the airplane would be.
And it's like a
Brownian motion thing.
And as soon as you hit
some critical threshold,
you would see there'd
be people with would
come together and say,
we've got to take weight out
of the airplane
somehow, again, right?
And then basically
try to get the design
to comply with that requirement
as you move through the design
process.
You can't do that with too
many of the requirements.
But the most important
technical performance
measures, that's what you do.
It's a big deal.
So here's the flow chart,
basically, for requirements.
I'm not going to go
through this in detail.
But the basic idea is the
inputs come from the stakeholder
expectations, the stakeholder
work we talked about a lot
last time.
You go through the
requirements definition process
and outcomes invalidated set
of technical requirements,
measures of performance
that you can measure,
and then these
technical performance
measures that you can then track
and validate against later.
Here's a question that
I often get asked.
Well, OK, so we write
these requirements.
You guys write them on
paper or your tablet.
But how do these requirements
actually get recorded, right?
And managed.
So I would say
there's sort of two--
there's the low cost,
and then there's
sort of the professional
version of doing this.
The easy way to do it
is you just write them,
you capture them in a document.
So that means Microsoft
Word, Excel, Google
Docs, just a document, a well
written, organized document.
And then you capture and
revise your requirements.
And the one thing I
strongly recommend
is using hyperlinks
to link requirements.
And this is the idea
that every requirement
has to be linked to
some other requirement.
So if it's a low level
requirement, you want to ask,
well, where does that come from?
Why did we write
that requirement?
Well, it has a
parent requirement.
You want to have
a hyperlink there
to get you from
one to the other.
And I have a little
example for that.
And I think this is OK for
smaller projects, where
you have dozens or a few
hundred requirements, right?
And so here's my rule
of thumb for this.
Do you remember
the magic number 7?
So we talked last
time, where does
the world of really
complex systems start.
And the argument was, well, if
you need more than three levels
of the decomposition.
What does that mean?
Well, 7 plus, minus
2 to the third power
is somewhere between
125 and 729, right?
So if you're sort of in
that world or fewer, right?
If a few hundred, a few dozen,
or few hundred requirements
kind of what we have in CanSat.
It's OK to do it this way.
It's still going to be
a lot of requirements.
And you have to do a good job.
But you can do it that way.
If you have more than that,
and that typically means
more than 1,000
requirements to handle,
and there are big projects
that have 5,000, 10,000
requirements, there is no way
you can manage that effectively
in a kind of document based way.
So what you need
then is a database.
You basically capture
the requirements
in a relational
database where that
allows you to link
each requirement
to other requirements.
And so this is not meant
as an advertisement,
but one of the most heavily
used requirements tools
out there is called, DOORS.
And this was relatively
recently bought by IBM.
This was a separate company.
It was bought by
IBM and included it
in a suite of software tools
called IBM Rational for System
Development.
And so DOORS allows you.
It's a database,
relational database,
that allows you to write
requirements, share
requirements.
And the latest version
of DOORS is actually
web based, so you can
have people in India,
in Europe, in the US, you're
co-developing a system.
You can all write
requirements and manage them
on this common database, right?
Because if you have a
document, very quickly
it's going to be
confusing, as what's
the latest version, who
has the latest update.
Version management
becomes a nightmare.
So just so you're aware of this.
We're not going to be
using DOORS in this class.
We'll just do it document based.
But you know the
rule of thumb here
is, more than
1,000 requirements,
you've got to go to some
professional solution.
So here's a very sort
of trivial example
of hierarchical
requirements with links.
Requirement one,
the systems shall
fit into a volume not
exceeding one cubic meter.
And then we have
sub-requirements.
The system's width shall
be between 0.5 and 1 meter.
The height, the depth.
The system shall
be made entirely
from aluminum 60/60 alloy.
A sub-requirement
here is the system
shall not contain any
internal voids or cavities.
Requirement three, the shape
of the system must be a cube.
And then a sub-requirement,
the angles between the sides
shall be 90 degrees
plus or minus 1 degree.
And so I did this here
just in the slides.
But if you click on this,
it'll actually transport you
into another requirement.
This is the requirement four.
The mass of the system shall not
exceed 2,700 kilograms, right?
Aluminum has a density
of about 2,700 kilograms
per cubic meter.
So I click back, it
transports me back
to the earlier requirement.
So the fact that it's made of
aluminum and the volume cannot
exceed one cubic meter,
then this requirement four,
the mass shall not exceed.
It's not an independent
requirement.
It's an dependent or
derived requirement
based on the first two.
And therefore, they're linked.
Do you see how this works?
And to really manage
requirements well and then link
them, use these hyperlinks.
It's very, very effective.
So what would be an object that
satisfies these requirements?
So here's our one
cubic meter envelope.
So an aluminum cube
with a side length
of 60 centimeters this
volume and this mass
will satisfy the requirements.
It's not the only thing.
There's a lot of
other geometries
that would satisfy it.
But this particular
instantiation
would satisfy
these requirements.
So that's the idea
hierarchical requirements,
linking them to hyperlinks.
OK, so let me talk briefly
about the challenges now
of requirements definition.
And there's-- this is not easy.
There's a lot of challenges.
The first one is
requirements allocation.
You know, there's composition
and flowing requirements
to the lower levels.
And then the idea
is that, whatever
requirements you derive
at a lower level,
if you satisfy the lower
level requirements, that
should guarantee that you then
automatically satisfy a higher
level requirements from
which the lower level
requirements were derived.
That's the basic idea of
requirements allocation.
And so the way you
can think of this,
graphically, is we start
out at the high level.
Here's our stakeholders.
Stakeholder needs requirements.
This is level 0.
You set the system boundary.
What's the lifecycle?
And then we apply it.
That's our first application.
And then we apply it by
decomposing the system
into its function.
And so that's the
second application.
And then you say,
well, how do these--
how will these companies
be carried out?
So we define subsystems.
And essentially, then,
the subsystem requirements
are derived from the
functional requirements.
And you put numbers, key
system performance parameters,
behind these.
And depending on the
complexity of the system,
you may have to go
multiple layers down.
But that's the basic
requirements allocation
process.
And I think I said this already.
It's difficult to do and
stay solution neutral
the deeper you go into this.
Let me briefly
mention, this will not
be, we will not sort
of test you on this.
But I want to make
you aware of this.
A methodology called
ISO performance.
And that was actually the
topic of my dissertation.
How do you allocate requirements
to lower level parameters
in systems, when a higher
level requirement is defined,
is clear.
So the idea is that you have a
vector of desired performance
requirements.
And you want to
understand, first of all,
you want to understand are
those requirements feasible.
And if they are
feasible, it usually
means there is more than one way
that these requirements could
be satisfied, that the higher
level requirements could
be satisfied.
So find different non-unique
feasible combinations
to satisfy the high
level requirements.
And so this is one
of the readings.
Very quickly, we have
our design space.
We have our objective space.
And then we have this
cost risk objective space.
And so the idea is that,
in the performance space,
you have the shall statements.
You shall perform at that level.
And that's this point here.
That's your performance target.
And if it's in this gray
area, it's actually feasible.
And it usually means there's
more than one way to do it.
So if you can then map
backwards to the design space,
these points here are
all ISO performance,
meaning they all
satisfy and provide
this level of performance.
But they do it in
different ways.
And then in order to
select the final design
or final requirements
set, you want
to look at other objectives.
This is where the should
statements come in.
And these are typically cost
and risk related objectives.
So let me give you,
this sounds pretty
abstract and theoretical.
Let me give you a
very specific example.
This was my case study,
the Space Telescope.
This is the actually this has
now become the James Webb Space
Telescope.
Hasn't launched yet.
This is 20 years ago.
We've been working on the
James Webb for a long time.
But if it works, it
will be exciting,
because it's going to get us
very, very close to the Big
Bang, right?
That's what James Webb will
look in the highly redshifted
infrared to really see the
formation of the earliest
proto-galaxies in the universe.
So if this works, it
will be very exciting.
So here's, essentially, a
model of the spacecraft.
This is a precursor
to James Webb.
And the big thing
you need to do is
you need to point and be very,
very stable for a long time
to take in these very,
very faint images.
So we have wavefront error
phasing requirements.
And then we have these
pointing requirements.
You've got to a point
very stable and in order
to achieve this optical
pointing performance,
we have the structure
of the spacecraft.
We have reaction wheels.
We have controllers.
And there is noise, different
kinds of noise sources
that are trying to basically
prevent us from pointing
with this precision.
So very quickly, this is what
this Nexus precursor spacecraft
looks like in the
deploy configuration,
here on the upper right in
the stowed configuration.
Initial performance assessment.
So this is really trying
to define the requirements
for deriving the requirements
for the structure,
for the optics,
for the controller,
knowing that this is the point.
If you want to have
this science happen,
you've got a point
with that precision.
That is known.
So let's flow that down.
So if we look at the pointing,
for example, here on the right,
this is kind of fuzzy furball.
What does that represent?
That's a time domain simulation
of the centroid of the image,
right?
The telescope is now
observing a part of the sky,
trying to get these
early proto-galaxies.
And it's flexible.
It's a very
lightweight telescope.
It has these reaction
wheels are turning,
trying to keep it stable.
You have electronic
sources of noise.
So the blue furball here
predicts that we would not
meet the requirements.
This is some initial
design, some initial set
of requirements.
We need to find a way
to get down to the--
this is about 15 microns--
[? root mean ?] square error.
So it's about three times worse
than what we need to achieve.
And the requirement
is we need to get down
to 5 microns of pointing
or jitter precision.
So how do we do this?
So what ISO
performance does is it
looks at the sensitivities
in the system.
What are all the
things that influence
the pointing performance
of the telescope.
And you can see here.
These are the two
key performance
measures on the left, wavefront
error, and then line of sight.
And the bars
essentially tell you
what are the really
sensitive parameters that
drive performance.
So disturbance parameters,
planned structural parameters,
optics, and then controls.
So it's really
multi-disciplinary.
And what's neat
about it is you can,
if you know these
sensitivities, you
can essentially calculate
the Jacobian a matrix.
The Jacobian matrix
is essentially
the partial derivatives
of your performance, which
is your higher level
requirement, with respect
to these lower level
parameters or requirements.
And you can then find, using
this essentially the null space
of the Jacobian matrix,
that will tell you
how do you move in that space
to keep the performance fixed
at the requirement level.
Let me explain this just
using two parameters.
And this was a big deal in
the Hubble Space Telescope.
So the two parameters
I'm going to use
are KR ISO and UD, the
dynamic wheel and balance.
So these spacecrafts
have reaction wheels
that are turning to
point the spacecraft
and counteract any momentum
that you get from, for example,
from solar pressure.
So UD is the amount of imbalance
that you have in these wheels.
If you have imbalance,
that will cause chatter.
It will cost torques, which
will cause that jitter.
And then KR ISO is the vibration
isolation of the reaction wheel
assembly.
How stiff or soft is
the vibration isolation.
And what you can
see in this clock
is that, our initial design--
this is based on a simulation--
does not satisfy a
higher level requirement.
In order to satisfy that, we
need to go down to the blue
line, labelled with 5
microns appointing precision.
And what you can see is that
there are different ways
to achieve that 5 microns.
We could go over here.
This is labeled as HST.
That's what Hubble
Space Telescope is.
The Hubble Space
Telescope basically
went for ultra, ultra,
ultra quiet reaction wheels,
very, very low
dynamic imbalance.
So [? Marissa, ?] you
talked about buying sensors
from a supplier and
putting them in.
These reactors,
there's companies
that really specialize
in making reaction wheels
and things like that.
So if you're going to
go for this point here.
Let me point that out again,
so you guys can see it at EPFL.
If you're going to go, if you're
going to derive and allocate
this requirement, it means
you put a lot of pressure
on your supplier to achieve
that level of dynamic wheel
imbalance.
If they can do it, that's great.
But it could be very expensive.
But it makes your job easier
as the spacecraft integrator.
Or you can go straight down to
this point here called spec.
So you're essentially tolerating
a noisier reaction wheel.
But then you need a very, very
soft, very capable isolation
stage, very soft isolator.
What's the disadvantage of
having very soft isolation?
What do you think
is the big issue?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So the launch.
You probably have to lock
it down during launch.
You have a big displacements.
You need, if you have a very
soft isolation stage, you
need volume,
because the isolator
is going to move a lot, right?
And you may not
have that volume.
Or you could do a
little bit of each.
So this test point here.
We're going to have quieter
wheels, but not ultra quiet.
And we're going to
have a soft isolator.
But we have the right
combination of the two.
And we're going to go
for that point there.
So now if you go for
that point, you're
going to satisfy your
pointing requirement,
bu you've allocate at the
lower level requirement,
in this case, to the isolation
stage and the dynamic wheel
imbalance in a kind
of balanced way.
So everybody's job is
roughly equally difficult.
That's the sort of idea here.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Does this model assume
that all of these variables
are independent
and, I guess, kind
of continuous in terms of you
can incrementally work better?
PROFESSOR: So they're not
independent in the sense
that they're coupled through
the performance of the system.
But you can choose--
the assumption is you
can choose these independently.
But they're coupled,
because you need
to achieve that requirement.
And yes, in this case,
they're continuous.
But you can think of this
as a discrete, as well.
So for example, the
reaction wheels could be,
you're picking from a
catalog, in which case
now you're really picking
specifications for components
that are off the shelf.
OK, so let me--
I'm going to skip here for time.
So basically, following this
ISO performance process,
you can go from some initial
requirements, derived
requirements that
are infeasible, to,
in blue here I'm showing
you the results of this.
It's very close to 5.
There's some numerical
tolerance here.
But by but essentially
rebalancing the requirements
within the system, we're
achieving a higher level
requirement.
But in a way that
this [INAUDIBLE]
sort of the challenge
equitably across sub-systems.
Does that make sense?
At EPFL, did you
guys follow this?
I know this was a bit fast.
But that's the basic
idea of ISO performance.
Any questions on your side?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Maybe I have one.
So given that you have
[? distance ?] requirements
and you probably have
[INAUDIBLE] for each one,
is there a way that we
would integrate all those
[? lines, ?] that you could
see the [INAUDIBLE] for those?
If you don't mind,
maybe it's a little bit
[? softer, ?] but maybe there's
another requirement where
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: We don't hear you.
PROFESSOR: Sorry, guys,
ran out of battery here.
Can you hear me again?
Can you hear me?
Yeah?
So the question was,
well if you have multiple
of these performance, ISO
performance lines, that's
exactly right.
If you have a vector of
higher level requirements,
you're going to have ISO
performance surfaces.
And so it gets, you
know, the more of these
you have to satisfy at the
same time, the more complex
this gets.
But we can handle
that computationally.
So you have to do some
simulation and computation
upfront to make sure you pick.
These requirements are
not just wild guesses.
They're actually based on some
calculation and simulation.
OK?
All right.
So let's do this.
Let's do this in a
kind of simplified way.
This is going to be our last
concept question for today.
Here's the higher level
requirement is a balloon.
Those of you that have done
unified engineering here,
you've done this, right?
We did this in unified.
A balloon shall lift the payload
of 1,000 kilograms, which
includes its own mass.
You can use either helium,
which has a density of 0.2
kilograms per cubic meters.
This is in standard
atmosphere conditions.
Or hydrogen, 0.1.
I've rounded these
numbers, as a lift gas.
The standard density
of air is 1.3.
Which of the following
requirements is infeasible?
A, the balloon
shall have a radius
of 6.1 meters and
the balloon shall
use 99.9 percent pure helium.
B, a radius of 5.9
and the balloon
shall use 99.99 point percent
hydrogen as a lift gas.
And then 5.9 meters helium,
6.1 meters hydrogen,
all these requirements
actually are OK.
Or none of these
requirements are feasible.
OK, so I'll give you I'll
give you three minutes
to try and figure this out.
And then I'll show
you the solution.
Don't cheat.
Don't go to the next chart.
So think about this the
high level requirement is
the balloon shall
lift 1,000 kilograms,
including its own mass.
And we're trying to allocate
lower level requirements
for the size of the
balloon and the gas
that we're going to use.
So try to figure this out.
All right, I think
we probably need--
who needs more time for this?
OK, so we're going to leave
this as a cliffhanger, OK?
We'll do the solution next time.
And take a little time
to figure this out.
Try not to look at
the next slide, OK?
So I'm going to skip
this just for time.
And I want to talk briefly about
the SRR, what it is, and then
kick off assignment 2.
So SRR.
So the idea is you've
really been working
on these requirements
hard, you know, as a team,
with your customers.
And this takes-- this
is not a quick thing.
This is not just
two or three days.
Typically, writing
your level 0, level
1 requirements is a process
that takes weeks, months,
sometimes at least a year.
But typically, it's on the
order of three to six months
in many projects, roughly.
And once you have your
high level requirements,
SRR is the milestone where
you review those, right?
So here's an example.
So it's a social.
It's a peer review process.
And the main goal of SBAR
is to vet the requirements
as they were written
to see if you have
any missing, misstated,
redundant, or otherwise
unsatisfactory requirements.
This is a picture from JPL,
from MSL, actually, mission.
And I want to just point
out a good friend of mine
who is a graduate here of our
department, Richard Kornfeld.
[? Voelker ?] knows him,
met him last summer.
He's been working on
three different Mars
missions over the last decade.
And we're going to
hear from Richard
later this semester about
verification of requirements,
because he verified the
entry descent and landing
requirements for MSL.
So here's essentially what
it says in the NASA handbook.
SRR happens during phase A,
before you go into phase B.
And you need at least your top
two level requirements written
before you can do the SRR.
I do want to mention the
second reading post reading.
This is about
requirements volatility.
So just because you
past the SRR doesn't
mean that the requirements
are completely frozen.
First of all, you don't have a
lot of lower level requirements
yet, right?
Those are going to
be added post SRR.
and even some of the--
you pointed out, some of
you, the requirements creep
and these things.
So this second reading is about
requirements volatility, which
you can actually quantify.
What are the sources of
requirements volatility?
That's what this
figure shows you.
And then what is the impact
of requirements volatility?
What is the impact of
requirements volatility
on a project?
So specifically, on the
number of system requirements,
on rework, on project
schedule, and so forth.
Really, it's a very,
very recent paper
on requirements volatility.
So let me just kick
off assignment 2.
And then we'll be done.
So assignment 2 goes out
today and is due in two weeks.
So that's October 9.
And it's very focused
on requirements.
Basically, what I want you-- and
it's the same teams that you're
in for all the assignments.
Is essentially, first
of all, first task
is find a project
or program where
poorly written or
managed requirements
were a major problem.
So as a team, discuss an
example and discuss that example
as a team.
The second task is look
at those CanSat 2016
requirements, those
47 base requirements
and analyze those critically.
So that means are they
feasible, are they well-written.
Classify them.
What type of requirement is it?
Is it an interface requirement?
Is it a performance requirement?
And then figure out whether
there's a hierarchy there.
And basically, then, from
that, generate your own set
of requirements for
the CanSat competition.
So you're going to either
rewrite or organize
these requirements in
a way that's better
and that works
for you as a team.
And then the fourth
requirement is
to figure out where
you want your margins,
where do you think you need
to have reserves and margins
in these requirements.
So it's very much
looking and reorganizing
and critically analyzing the
CanSat 2016 requirements set.
So let me summarize.
Good requirements
are really essential.
It's the starting point
for system design,
system engineering.
It is a challenging
thing, especially
the flow down is challenging.
There are some methods and
commercial tools for doing
formal requirements management.
So I mentioned ISO performance.
And then I mentioned DOORS,
these commercial tools.
And then the last point here
is just because you passed SRR,
and you have high level
requirements approved,
doesn't mean that's
the end of the story.
The requirements will continue
to be updated, refined.
But you have to be you
have to be very disciplined
to keep that in check.
If your requirements
volatility is too high,
then bad things can
happen to your project.
And I really
recommend the reading
on requirements volatility, some
very, very recent data on that,
OK?
So that's the end of
the session for today.
I'm going to be online on the
WebEx in about 10 minutes.
If any of you have questions,
or any comments, or you
want to dive into this further.
I know this is not a great
time for you at EPFL,
because it's Friday
night for you guys.
So I think what
we're going to do,
we'll figure this out with
[? Leighs ?] and [? Johana. ?]
We'll see if we want
to do a separate time,
a different time during the
week for the office hours.
I'm happy to do this
at a better time,
if this doesn't
work for you guys,
because it's happy
hour time for you.
So anyway.
OK, so great.
Have a great week.
And we'll see you next Friday.